i have some i have some questions i
would like to um
speculate on pontificate as it were
man i'm really wondering if we're going
to see the biggest red wave that's ever
red waved not that i think the
republicans are good or effective or
going to do anything
but you look at what's happening with
joe biden his popularity's in the gutter
independent voters are revolting they're
saying well
saying it that way is probably not the
right way to say it they're revolting
they're in revolt
they're in revolt against joe biden
regular people at stadiums are chanting
f joe biden i mean you look at the
public sentiment at jets games like a
football game
at the nascar stuff i get f joe biden
let's go brandon whatever
people are are absolutely like in revolt
so you look at the school boards
finally you get regular people
showing up to these events and they're
yelling and there have been instances of
violence and there have been meetings
shut down because people have made
threats i tell you man when regular
people are seeing their kids affected
this way
this is what i hear from everybody
they say tim it's easy for you to say
stand up for what you believe in because
you don't have kids i can't sacrifice
feeding my children you know my kid's
future over a job or political belief
and my response is usually like you
can't comply your way out of this if you
are worried about feeding your kids when
you give in to the state during a time
of food shortages when they've shuttered
the economy and destroyed hundreds of
thousands of small businesses you think
doing this will result in your kids
having more food wow i'm impressed i
think it's actually the acceleration
towards your kids not eating
but then regardless of that position
when the parents still comply
and and many of them have and we have we
have people on the show who talk about
it
and then you see what the schools are
doing to their kids
that's the red line for a lot of these
parents they're like i could go along
with some of this i could go along with
what the government was saying we had to
do the restrictions the lockdowns and
that's it because now they're going to
their kids forcing them to wear masks
they're they're doing vax mandates
they're doing a whole bunch of weird
racist programming stuff and now people
are like my kids are being threatened
that says to me
when these parents take their kids out
of these schools when these parents go
to these meetings you know they talk to
other parents you know they go to
meetings you go you know they go on chat
rooms they are talking about this you're
not going to see it in the polls but i'm
wondering will this result in a major
red wave not just in 2022 but maybe
locally
maybe even in 2024
or maybe not it's hard to tell i mean
i'm disenfranchised and i believe a lot
of people are disenfranchised with
republicans uh but it's not just you
know kids being threatened they're also
being punished for
their masks slipping off by accident or
being too close to a colleague and a lot
of parents really got first-hand point
of view of what's happening in these
schools because of the lockdowns and
everything was digital and their parents
were watching their children and they
were listening to their teachers talk to
their kindergarteners about sexual adult
topics that they shouldn't be talking
about talking about issues about hating
someone because of the way that they
were born talking about other ridiculous
issues that have nothing to do with
actual useful skills i posted a meme
today and it was about things that you
should teach your children that the
local public school doesn't and i'm just
going to read this off really quickly
because i find this very important and
this might motivate some people to do
some homeschooling which is absolutely
critically important if we want a free
and independent nation not just
bootlegging slaves that will repeat and
regurgitate everything that they're
taught to in these indoctrination
centers but first off safety
self-defense how to grow your own food
basic survival skills how to start your
own business how to be an entrepreneur
mental health awareness how to read a
map navigate without communications how
to avoid debt budgeting basic first aid
self-regulation meditation bodily
autonomy all of those things are never
taught to school children and they are
essentially key important skills to have
to be able to be an adult and that's
something that a lot of people are
having a very hard time dealing with
especially when they leave these
indoctrination centers these little safe
spaces and they're out there in the real
world and they get a shock of what the
world really is imagine imagine being
one of these parents who still genuinely
believes that your kids going to school
and learning math
i have to wonder like what do they ask
their kids when they come home from
school you know but but but here's the
thing a lot of these parents they'll
watch msnbc they'll see the russiagate
lies they'll see all the fake social
justice stuff and they'll see joy reid
be like there's no critical race theory
in schools and the parent will go there
is no critical race theory in schools
and then joyride comes on and says there
is no war in boston saying the parents
chime right back there is no war
embossing to say math has even been
racialized and there's even some
teachers saying two plus two equals five
that's the level of ridiculousness i
have again that's the regular like like
where are we as a nation to be at this
specific point with this absolute lunacy
and and people rightfully so are getting
involved in in their local communities
and their school boards and one thing
that they could be doing is setting up
collectives of of local communities
coming together and saying hey i i know
math i know geometry i know history and
we could create little you know
sustainable units some people call them
pods uh of people
using each other's skills to raise their
children in the proper right way that
doesn't teach them just to regurgitate
what the teacher tells them but what
kills me was it two plus two equals five
was just the starting point yes that was
the starting point and now it's 3.5
trillion equals zero yes
literally and that i mean it's not just
one it's not just biden said that they
they parroted it yeah like literally
like they can get away with it because
we started with two plus two equals five
i mean there there's some relation there
but i think that the 3.5 billion uh 3.5
trillion is actually zero is one of the
funniest things because there's been
this this irs rule change they pushed
through that they can track any account
that has at least six hundred dollars in
it in trent i think it's in in an
account with 600 or more they track your
net income versus you know outgoing
revenue which basically means they're
not tracking every transaction they're
just tracking how much money you have
and i think this is another example of
them going after the little guy of
course the progressives are like this is
so they can tax the rich
you know what's funny
you've got to be a special person
if you can see them say
i will be tracking your bank account
that's what literally the democrat said
we'll track your bank accounts that have
at least this is in biden's buildback
better agenda the spending bill
600 or more we track your revenue
they say this will allow us to capture
lost tax revenue
from the rich
well then why six hundred if you're
going after the wealthy six million yeah
well why not sixty thousand yeah and
having sixty thousand dollars doesn't
make you rich
you know no no we need to go after the
billionaire class i think because
they're the ones calling for all these
taxes and regulations to make sure that
no one competes against them right or no
one even rises against them if you see
the biggest proponents of the minimum
wage of more regulations of more
government intervention it's the
multinational corporations that have
already made it and they're afraid and
they want to solidify their position so
uh why aren't there any calls to
regulate them or or go after them this
this plays a it plays into exactly what
i'm saying though with um you know
parents rising up it's also regular
people i mean
if you genuinely believe the democrats
proposing a new irs rule to track your
bank account is to text the rich
well then i guess we're doomed but i
think a lot of people are going to be
like yo wait a minute what is this
why are why is my net income being you
know for this amount of money
because they're trying to track the side
hustle the people who make very little
money listen people who are rich they
don't need to do these these look when
they do these massive secretive
transactions like in movies to
switzerland and then they're like what's
the password that's all fake they don't
need to do that they're rich they don't
care about paying fees or paying taxes
when you have a billion dollars in
assets they certainly try to avoid them
to the best of the best of their
abilities but they can say look i i've
met people who do like art deals
where these wealthy people are like i
can toss 50 million at this no big deal
how much do you want a million bucks
done and people get rich for doing
nothing i've seen that stuff rich people
aren't as concerned as people as the
poor really do think about taxes they
don't want to pay it obviously they'll
go to panama they'll go to switzerland
they'll go wherever they have to ireland
saint kitts and nevis
but when they're tracking 600
what they're really saying is you as a
poor person we know you've got side
hustle because most people do
most people might be like i sold a car
for you know a couple thousand bucks and
then the irs is gonna be like you're
gonna get a letter in the mail and if
you've not experienced this you will
after if this rule passes you'll get a
letter in the mail would be like your
account saw an increase of x amount of
dollars that was unreported
you owe us taxes on that what is this
income you failed to report
and then they're going to come after
everything yep and this is at the same
time that the biden administration has
just announced that they're spending
millions of dollars on expanding the irs
hiring as many agents as they can just a
few weeks ago they just announced this
so this is in correlation with this for
total track trace and database society
where they're trying to push everyone
into a cashless society so they could
control everyone and have the ability to
turn people's wallets off
the bigger pictures my question is
will this be the the straw that breaks
the camel's back not just not the
schools right taxes usually but it's
like these grains of sand making this
heat taxes for sure
no taxation without representation the
famous you know statement from the
american revolution but we're gonna have
regular people who are like yo dude i
make like a hundred bucks a week by you
know helping my neighbor and now they're
questioning me on where this money came
from and i gotta pay taxes on it well
the truth is you're supposed to pay
taxes on that if you do a job but there
are a lot of poor people who don't
report the stuff a lot of servers don't
report cash tips all of a sudden now
those cash tips yeah they're gonna be
asking questions about how you have so
much money here's the best part you
notice you notice the change shortage
over the past uh two years
we went to i think we went to a golden
corral and they were like we don't
accept cash because we have no change
exact change required or credit so
naturally everyone goes credit like luke
said cashless society but again the
bigger picture is
are people going to snap from this i'm
kind of thinking when you look at the
parents
and you look at the financial situation
they are just turning up the heat so
fast that people are going to explode
i mean we'll see it's very hard to
predict a lot of these things i would
definitely guarantee that an
intelligence agency has some kind of
predictive programming tracking
everyone's discontent against completely
what's happening right now but but also
just to kind of go back to what we were
originally talking about i just saw this
article by town hall that says quote fbi
admits it doesn't track antifa blm
violence with a quote from the fbi
saying quote since we don't categorize
anti-far nor do we calculate or
calculate information regarding antifa
that movement we don't have information
on their terrorist attacks i'm going to
push back on that a little bit though
because i looked into that story
the full statement he gave was that we
don't actually track specific groups
and so i can what he said was so i can
tell you about anarchist extremism but
we don't target any specific group so a
lot of people frame that as them saying
like we don't track antifa
well it sounds like he was saying they
do they just call it anarchist violence
they track everyone but who they choose
to go after is another thing and this is
why george soros has invested so much
into local prosecutors and he's
investing a lot right now into a local
race happening in austin
specifically to make sure that the local
prosecutors there that there's going to
be
a bill that's up for vote about police
officers because they want to hire more
police officers in austin
george soros is spending a ton of money
down there making sure that that
proposition doesn't get passed thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you